here's a fun thing I found out about you
though you nicknamed yourself what is it
black mamba okay I'm gonna just keep it
family but what where'd that come from
well honestly I stole it from Quentin
Tarantino's Kill Bill yeah but it was
like you know if you look up the black
mamba the snake it's extremely deadly
you know I'm saying so like for me when
I play basketball that's the space I go
into it's like exactly yeah leave me
alone
maybe my nickname could be sports ball
I'm just kidding your official name is
Kobe bean Bryant so where did Comey and
bean come from I I think it came from my
parents mocha something that was illegal
they're the crazy like big they
literally the story that they've told me
is that where they were sit at a
Japanese Steakhouse yeah it's all Kobe
beef on the menu it was like oh that's a
good name and then my middle name is
beanie so it's like steak and beans
right now so where didn't bean come from
my father's nickname when he played was
Joe jelly bean bryant jelly bean all
right
he says I'm trying to make it cool go no
ain't no saving then your dad played do
that you did yeah he played for uh eight
years in the NBA and then play eight
years overseas in Italy so right that's
right cuz I found out you also speak
Italian I do
that's sexy Italian well ciao I do tha
they studied Greek
what does that mean it means hello
everybody it's a pleasure to be here
okay and Santa it was cooler my meaning
was clear telling you so damn sexy
that's right filtered it I will not stop
talking until you subscribe to my
YouTube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this